um
in the council chamber today and those
on live stream
to the extraordinary infrastructure
meeting 29th
march 2021
right we're going to start with
apologies
and i have them from councillor abbott
and from lindsay mckenzie uh
his worship is here
can i have someone please move those
apologies
councillor soper secondary council lewis
put the motion all those in favor
right first uh interest register i've
had no updates
and nothing to declare so we'll move on
to the first item which is the long term
plan asset long term plan
asset and activity plans now rhiannon
welcome hello i'm gonna switch
i'm too short to have that little short
chair um thank you chair
um just to um take the report as read
these
are the last um plans for the committee
to receive a head of consultation
um the property or building asset plan
rather
obviously needed the strategic project
process to complete
and also the housing consultation and
that's why you're receiving these plans
now okay
right so with the recommendations are
quite straightforward
that we confirm the plans
and they are the draft property asset
plan the draft housing care activity
plan
and the draft public toilets activity
plan um
i'm going to open it up for discussion
if anyone has anything to say before i
remove these
no okay can i please have someone move
that
we adopt please thank you councillor
crack at secretary councillor sopa put
the motion all those in favor
all right right we move now to
the hearings for the regional public
transport plan
and georgia there is
this one there is
so we'll just take that report as read
there are a couple of things to note so
with the regional public transport plan
these submission process have been um
undertaken
by environment southland the submissions
opened on the 16th of march
and are closing on the top of april
we have so far received three
submissions
and of those three one person wants to
be heard
hearings for this consultation will take
place on the 27th of april
at 11am so the key thing today is
to seek nominations for a
hearing panel for those hearings of
three counsellors
so we already have the chair councillor
pohinja
we need two more but just as a side
we have a long-term plan engagement
event happening on that same day
which uh councillors are monster and
sopa
uh will be attending so if we could have
two
other councillors not them too
thanks georgia i'll just ask the
committee who who would like to be on
this hearing panel we've got three
submissions did you say
that's correct yeah at this moment
council ludlow and oh
counselor skill sorry you're is that
right i don't mind if i want to not just
okay i just had the first i'll put you
down as a backup
um council lewis just in case right so
um i've had the name sport of council
ludlow councillor skelt
i'm going to move that they be the two
um uh
hearings panel members that join me can
i have a second to please
with councillor lewis as the backup
counselor kit and councillor craic at
second did i put the motion on those in
favor
okay and that's that part done
but we have to receive the report which
we've done
and we have to note the hearings for the
regional land
transport plan and that the southland
regional
regional public transport plan which is
the one that we're doing here
so i'm going to put those all again as
one lot
i'll move that now have a second to
please
counselor super thank you promotion all
those in favor
great that moves us on now to the
roading and
traffic bylaw review
and speak to that
welcome russell i get the loach here you
pop up and just go
thanks mr chairman um
this is the uh bylaw uh revisiting which
which we um
have head out to public consultation
between november and
9th of december last year we had 12 12
submissions
and after discussion with some of those
people no one wished to be heard
most of the submissions that we received
were predominantly focused around i
guess amending the speed
and after some consultation with nzta
they've said that we need to directly
consult on speed
which we propose to do through the
middle part of this year
so the changes that we're proposing to
the previous bylaw
through this consultation process are
relatively minor
and we're proposing this routing and
traffic bylaw
will be operational operative from the
first of july
this year coming and in recommendation
five it is a recommendation to council
which seeks your council to
adopt the bylaw so thanks very much mr
chairman
it is noted in recommendation
six that obviously it's
the door is still open to change
uh things at a later time is that
correct
that's correct mr chairman you certainly
can um with a speed by-law
and it's likely that we will look to
introduce a specific by-law relating to
speed because speed is seems to be one
of a
um certainly an area where the community
has lots of interest and there's lots of
change
to i guess occur in the wider context
right okay um any discussion counselors
all right quite a lot oh yes counselor
sophomore oh sorry
uh mr i was just going to say there's no
questions i was going to say i was
having to remove the
recommendations well it seems to be no
question so
um i'll accept that you move these
recommendations second to place
thank you councillor skel we'll put
those
six recommendations all those in favor
against that is carried that moves us on
to the
parking control bylaw review
russell thanks mr chairman this and this
this is a
another one of the i guess the important
roading bylaws that
that i have and this is the one that
actually sets um
the parking restrictions and parking or
the use of parking in the city so that
our
enforcement team can keep the traffic
moving
once again we consulted between the 10th
of november and
the 9th of december had nine nine
submissions and
again no one wishes to be heard
the bylaw is proposed to be operative
from the first
first of july the report sets out the
areas where we
see the significant i guess the changes
from
the current bylaw which are there to
help
highlight those changes um there are
some
thoughts a little bit um with our new
equipment and how we'll go about it so
that's hopefully reasonably
self-explanatory
i do think we will have to probably
revisit this bylaw
as the city centre changes and we will
have to
uh i guess address changes in the
street by street parking so there is an
opportunity and then
in the report there are there is a table
of a number of minor amendments that i
need to bring
to get approved so that the plans can be
updated which are attached to the back
of the bylaw
right any discussion
anyone here one question oh sorry
counselor cricket here we go
got a question um the question was
regarding um and i've had to read
through this but i may have missed it is
the
as where the uh bylaw operates
you know where where it kicks in or is
it going to be 24 7.
just i was just thinking of when people
go out at evening
and uh require um perhaps a longer
parking time you know for restaurants or
whatever as opposed to your
normal nine til five shopping
um i would need to check but i would
have expected the
bylaw to have been operative
monday to friday and during business
hours and on saturday mornings but i
need to is that something that we have
to write down just
in case of interpretation you know like
do we have to include it and uh
um i would need to check but um it
should be stated i would agree
yeah no i had a bit of a look but i just
couldn't find it yeah
sorry uh councillor cracker um thank you
mr chair
um i'm really pleased to see these
amendments come forward it's
um i think that they'll offer a lot of
convenience with the new kiosks uh
in the center city i mean i'm sure that
most of our community has experienced
this type of technology in other regions
um some of those advantages being that
if you've got the app
and you could be at work or you could be
out shopping and decide that you
actually want to stay in town a little
bit longer than
than you currently are and then use that
app to
up your time period or period of paid
parking without having to return to your
vehicle
it also gives us a lot more control uh
where we can um extend
uh payment periods or a time that you
could spend parking
in town or have uh parking free holidays
or all sorts of things so i'm really
pleased to see this
i am happy to move the
recommendations as they stand
thank you um russell
um i just can't identify it but we could
i can report
i guess to council or we could
con i think i just would like the
opportunity to perhaps just check and
come back
i just think it's one of these critical
ones where you actually know when it
when it kicks in and not you don't get
sort of called out at
seven o'clock if you're dining at six
and those are just
sort of occurred to me the other
question was the uh
it would have stayed on the kiosk i
believe that's correct like
at the moment our existing meters have
have it on and our kiosks will actually
have
the applicable times it just doesn't
note it in the
in the bylaw that's all um the other
question
was regarding the app but it did say
that
hopefully the app would be like a com
like one that may be abused around the
place so that
you know we weren't
other districts here so mr chairman at
the moment we have a proposal for
um received a proposal for the kiosks
and the app
and at the moment we're reviewing and
assessing those
we would certainly be looking to have an
app that is
consistent with others that you don't
have to have
three different apps if you wanted an
even one in queenstown i know that i
think wellington has six different
applicable ones but we would ideally
only have one
that would actually be able to be used
so no that's that's good
okay so we've had these moved by
councillor crackit
um seconded by councillor sapper i take
it or are you wanting to i
i am seconding happily but i just wanted
to also
add that while it may sound very
old-school
i am pleased that coins can still be
utilized as a payment option because i'm
well aware
um and have had comments from a number
of elderly people on that very question
so i think it's good that we are moving
with the times but also recognise that
we have
some members of the population who will
be happier to
know that coins are still available
okay so no further comments we have the
four
recommendations in front of us like put
the motion all those in favor
against is carried
and i would like to
call the meeting over thank you for
participating
are we still streaming live or do we
adjourn for the next meeting
you've closed the meetings
yeah i realized that but you don't do um
uh
apparently a silver medal is quite good
good afternoon your worship councillors
staff member of the public members of
the public and the press
i'll declare this uh extraordinary
meeting of performance policy and
partnerships
open we have apologies
as per previous from councillor abbott
and also lindsay mckenzie if somebody
would like to move
councillor lewis seconded councillor
pottinger
uh also to note that uh andy burns may
from audit may zoom in at some point as
well
so we've got the apologies moved in
second i'll put the motion all in favor
against carried
first up on a full house we won't set a
uh
set of tests at the end of it because i
appreciate the amount of reading
that sits in here but of course most of
this has been before
us before
i was pretty tired by the time i got to
halfway through the fees
and um charges and then realized of
course that
i had noted these before that was a late
late friday night we've got the free
fees and charges schedule as proposed
for 21.22
here rhiannon is there anything you'd
like to add in speaking to your report
thank you chad i'll take the report as
read um
this is the fees and charges schedule
for consultation
consultation will take place alongside
the long-term plan
just to remind counsellors that you made
a decision last year when selling the
fees and charges to increase the
professional charge out rates
which are used for some services known
as the corporate fees across
three years so that has been taken into
account with this
setting of the fees and charges for this
year um
the changes proposed or outlined in
summary the substantial changes for each
area
um and just to say we're proposing
removing the airport fees and charges as
it's the cco there is no requirement to
consult on these
fees and charges at this time thanks
random
two recommendations is the remover
happy to move councillor sopa secondary
councillor eminson
it's open for questions councillor clark
sorry mr chair um in
on page 12 of our records it says the
animal services have no changes and you
when i look at
page 21 there is an increase for the
registration of working dogs it goes
from 35
up to 150 so that just
raises a flag i guess
sorry cats are you talking about animal
services yes animals
dog control fees registration so see is
the 20 21
fee is 34 currently 35 which is low for
working dogs
and it's proposed it goes up to 150.
um which is higher than that's that's
puts it on a level with menacing and
dangerous dogs
okay that's an error then in that cover
report
so apologies for that that's right so
that should remain
as it was so no the schedule is correct
so it will be my summary i probably
should have written no changes other
than with working
councillor dogs that begs another
question then uh i guess that um
it seems to me that we've gone from a
situation where a working dog was
rested at a much lower rate than a
residential dog
um and we've pushed that up and like to
have some
logic for that given it's at the same
rate as what we would charge for a
menacing or dangerous dog which is quite
a bit of work for us
just from memory before i ask for an
answer i think
there is a set fee for a maximum number
of dogs as well
five or more i think from memory
which which caps it um
who would like to handle this rhiannon
or darren i'll refer this to
darren
perhaps if i can take that away
and i'd like to understand is
you're gonna have to take that away and
come back rather swiftly because we're
to confirm them at the following meeting
thanks thanks councillor clark any other
points you wish to raise
well there's just one other quick thing
sorry i was still with councillor
council o'clock
thank you sorry no counselor i was just
going to say the additional late fee
after the first september goes from 25
percent of registration to 50 percent
presuming that's an increase as well
yes uh and that's to encourage people to
register on time
all right that's just that i thought
there's no changes to it
if if you look at page
12 of your agenda in the summary table
it says a 50 late fee for dog
registration is proposed after first of
september
to replace the earlier fee and this is
to bring council into line with fees set
by south and district and goal district
that's the reason put forward by the
animal services team
and that's what they're recommending
councillor cricket um thank you mr chia
um it's
i think it's worth noting that these
fees and charges the schedule
that has been put forward to us is again
to
go out concurrently for consultation any
feedback that we do have on animal
services or any discrepancies and
differences and fees and charges i
believe will come out in the wash with
consultation
and we'll hear from our community i'm
comfortable with
hopefully getting an answer from the
animal services or from
through darren that we again ask what
our community's opinion is on
our fees and charges settings and go
forward with consultation
thanks councillor if there are no other
comments i'm prepared to leave this one
just sitting on the table bearing in
mind that we're going to confirm this in
the in the meeting that follows so i'll
give
darren a chance to seek some
clarification and come back to us
um we've got a weight of other ones to
get through so
hopefully that'll buy him some time
councillors are you happy
comfortable enough with that yeah thanks
so that takes us through to the uh
supplementary materials for consultation
there's um one or two
in fact from memory i think it's the
first time we managed to get through the
entire alphabet on one of the points
which is uh the the second point
um so it was a task well well
well done thanks for the reason
if that was your existence were there
other ambitions you'd care to share with
me
or for the remainder of the report
um again i'll take this report as read
and i think in this case if that really
is the case because most of these
materials counselors you will have
received before you're receiving them
all again
so that you can have the absolute final
version and see the packaging materials
together
as the report notes these are all the
supplementary materials for the
consultation
the majority of these will be on the
website roadmap to renewal which will
launch
when we launch consultation um
obviously we've been through the audit
process now and i see that andy has just
joined
the meeting um and so there are some
small changes that have been made
to activity plans and asset plans
some of the financial materials
that i've put up here all of those noted
under 0.2 there are not
substantial changes so they're provided
again for your reference
i've pointed you to the three areas
uh where you may want to focus on the
more substantial
substantive changes as a result of audit
so under recommendation poor
that's the financial strategy where
there's been a change to some wording
around a debt and michael may wish to
speak more
to that or he may not he does not
the key assumptions document where there
have been some changes as a result of
the audit process
to reflect really taking a completionist
approach
i guess so we've included some new
assumptions around cobit 19 and the
potential implications for rates income
asset life investment property and
forestry
capital program delivery asset
revaluation
and interest rates and some changes to
the
risk of uncertainty so i think that's
just important to note when it comes to
assumptions that they are of course
just that they are assumptions around
forecasting which are used for modeling
they are not in any way looking into a
crystal ball and knowing what the future
is going to hold
as a general principle we've taken a
conservative approach
in order that the finance team when
building the budget we're able to
put together something that the
community could be sure
was was built in that conservative
manner so that covers off the key
assumptions
and then the third element which has
been revised as the revenue and finance
policy
so that's just to note that we're now
including information within that policy
that will enable the public to see the
difference
between the proposed rating approach
and the existing rating approach if the
revenue and
finance policy was not to be updated so
this provides a greater amount of
information
for the public and that is noted as well
in the consultation document
so that's all i'll say to this report
thanks rhianna
so councillors we have uh four
recommendations
which include a reasonable number of
subset of other recommendations
um as the remover and the secondary for
the recommendations
i'm happy to move those councillors and
councillor partinger
it's open for questions or comments at
this point bearing in mind that this
is the draft that goes out for
consultation shortly
there's still a process whereby we want
to
seek feedback we talked at the workshop
the other day how we would like to
encourage as many people as possible
to submit so if you have any feedback
on what's contained in the full
recommendations
now's the time
i supported going out to
consultation
thank you your worship counselor clark
um
just like to backtrack a little bit onto
the previous
very long list of uh um in
in five the material for consultation or
supplementary i've just got some
questions there if you'd
allow that absolutely okay um
on page one five
three which is the significance and
engagement draft policy
from my recall of the last one that we
had i think we had
in there a monetary criteria as well and
it seems to be
not there in this draft so i wonder
whether somebody with a bit more
experience for me
could help me with that so previously it
had a dollar amount if a project was
over a dollar amount you had to sort of
go out and consult
so and it seems that that's gone so
somebody continue to comment on that
just give you a chance to
just trying to find the page sorry oh
sorry
just throw yourself the chair um
counselor
you're possibly right that it was there
previously
um i'll have to double check that myself
just in relation to
a mission there um we have had a look in
in relation to some changes that have
gone through
around significance policy um across
loca uh the local government and
government network
network recently um but i have to say i
will
will have to have another look to double
check to see if we should bring that
back in
thank you answer that question oh yeah
i've got several thank you um and page
one one six
zero nine um it refers to us now having
a critical rating of double a
plus previously double a minus is that
is that correct and so that's a real
plus
terrible pun but that's good that we've
we've got to there
um on um
page one six one zero where it talks
about cash investment and
this sits at the issue of what is net
debt
my recollection of the um risk insurance
meeting we just
recently had we got a treasury report
initial interim treaty report and my
recollection was that the amount of
investment we had was about 50 million
dollars not 40.
i don't have that at hand but i did do a
quick
tally up on the day
yes please thanks mike through yourself
yes the net debt um does change between
um and investments to change between
times
we've had the repayment occurring in
relation to
uh council decision just recently in
relation to
holco so we've had some movement in the
investment and net debt position from
that respect
thank you on page one six
double one it talks about um
this council imposing um rate increase
limits
of 7.5 and i just wonder michael how
that will fit with the
current realignment of the rates that
we're doing that's going to push about
13 or 14 of our rate payers into 10
plus so it doesn't quite align with that
yes through yourself the chair the 7.5
cap that's been placed within that
policy
benchmark is is across
the entire um
rates increase for the entire
city from that perspective it's not a
per property assessment
that takes into many factors and has a
lot of
variability in relation to those
increases that's
through the consultation i think we've
got something there for people to see
two other quick things um on page one
six one two
it talks about two commercial properties
and it lists don street but it seems to
be silent on the arrow farm so whether
it's just a typo
because normally those two would be
clustered together
through self-chair that is correct we
have only listed the one
at this point as an example we would be
possible to add the other one
if so desired and the final question
um is on 1628
which continues to talk about the
need to annually review the forestry
assets and i just wonder whether that's
still appropriate given
where we're going with the forestry
assets and the company itself
at this point we still need to keep
forestry um
revaluations in there as as a
requirement if we have forestry from
that perspective going forward at this
point there is none in the plan
from recent decisions it doesn't take
into account the forestry that sits with
parks and reserves
it does um but we don't have any
forest per se apart from those that are
already in our
parks and recreation services
comfortable with that thank you cheer
thanks
councillor partner um just continuing
the forestry thing
um the ones at sandy point are
managed in a commercial way they are
um they are felled and then they are
replanted so it's more than
it's more than a than thinking about
queen's park and chopping down trees
that are about to fall over
um it's my belief that the sandy point
arrangement is a commercial operation
and we'll continue that way and
i guess it's seen i mean it's not as
probably as cyclic
as as a full commercial
arrangement where there will be gaps
between filling and then but but i would
see it as a full commercial operation
just as
a true investment
otherwise with our carbon credits and
everything would be going a bit crazy
yeah
thanks for the explanation councillor
any other questions
or comments on the supplementary
materials
counselor i do have on the confirmation
of the long-term plan is that the
appropriate type of that
uh we're not the no we're not quite
there yet thank you
no others if not then it's been moved
and seconded i'll put the motion
all in favor against
carriage council let's uh thank you for
your questions through that uh just to
confirm
uh if we go back to the fees and charges
the ongoing fee for working dog is still
70
uh 35 so that is a typo it's not an
increase to 150 it will still be
35 so therefore the only change in
animal fees is for the late payment fee
which is signaled
in rhiannon's paper thank you
mr chairman can i ask a question
regarding the dog fees please
um well it's kind of naughty because we
did go through that before but
go ahead well i've just been looking
uh racing dogs which category do they
come under
i should know the answer to this
they're not classified as a working dog
but
from memory they
mostly fall under that um that bulk
payment so if you've got five or more
dogs there's a capped
fee so there aren't many people who hold
racing dogs for active racing that don't
have more than
than five animals
so there are a few that have more than
five yeah so that's what they've got a
capped
fee that they pay yeah but from memory
they are not classified as a working dog
yeah they do get the reduced fee because
they're responsible owners
unless proved otherwise
thank you some flashbacks that i'm
having from past hearings about dog fees
which is why
that kind of still sits there okay so
if we're going back to the fees and
charges motion uh that came forward
before we were seeking
uh further clarification you've had that
now so that motion
has been moved and seconded i'll now put
that
all in favor against
carried which brings us to the
confirmation
of the long-term plan uh
2021-2031 consultation document of
course you've got a
hard copy printed out uh andy burns has
joined us
from audits welcome along andy
thank you good afternoon everybody uh do
you have any comment that you'd
like to offer council in in
your observations in working through the
document with staff
okay maybe i'll i'll keep this short i'm
sure you've got a full agenda
i mean the main observation is the audit
complete and you have with you today
a copy of the ordered opinion that of
all opinions basically says
that we've looked at the supporting
information for the consultation
document
we've considered whether it's founded on
evidence and whether it's integrated in
other words whether the infrastructure
strategy talk to financial strategies
talk to the financial model
talk to the cd and we're comfortable in
that space
we've looked at the console data and
document itself and i have to say
it was great to get a consultation
document to start the audit that was
really well
pulled together and prepared and
polished we've added to that to that
debate but it was great to get that from
the start
uh our opinion is going to have three
areas of emphasis um
all councils will have an area of
emphasis around the water reforms
and error of emphasis is simply saying
there's a level of risk
or the level of uncertainty in certain
areas of this plan
uh for all councils there's water reform
the forms not too far away they'll
obviously change the face
of the planet if they go ahead so
there's no uncertainty there for
planning
and there are two specific to
invercargill
one is the level of reliance that you're
placing on external funding and so for
some of your consultation areas
i think in total you're assuming 19.2
million
across mag across rugby park and the
urban play area
so there's a level of uncertainty to
that because nothing's signed up at this
point in time
you've talked to an expert you've come
to an estimate of what you might get
but clearly if you don't get that money
there's a signal in this
consultation document that you'll go
back to consider either consider future
options or go back to the right pair
again to consult on what you want to do
so an area of uncertainty there in terms
of external funding
and the third one is about the capital
program itself um
councils well all organizations probably
struggle to deliver a capital program
um this capital program you have that
underpins this plan
is particularly ambitious um it's kind
of a step
change from the previous 2018 ltp
uh so so you put in play into place of
pmo
another other factors to try to manage
your ability to deliver but
a lot of risk there again around simply
your ability to deliver the capital
programme
within a 10-year period on top of that
you've got your specific consultation
areas that will obviously have further
you know significance to the size of the
capital program so it's a clean opinion
and you've got it it's there to adopt
with the consultation document
but three areas of risk uh that we're
particularly highlighting in the audit
opinion itself
that'll go out when it goes out when you
adopt it
thanks andy i guess there's there's not
a great deal of surprise for council in
the areas that you've identified
certainly with three waters we know that
we're
paddling in the same waka as other
councils there around the capital
projects
it is certainly an issue that staff have
gone to some length
to make sure that we are aware of
going into it and being constantly
updated on as well and we've had to bear
that in mind
as we've put together the long-term plan
for consultation so
thank you for your comments and thank
you for for working with our staff to
get
uh get the opinion through in time we
appreciate it
pleasure councillors there are four
recommendations i'm looking for a move
and a second to please councillor arnold
and councillor sopa thank you it's open
for
questions or comments
counselor clark thank you thank you
champ um
i just want to signal with my colleagues
that i'm opposed to the
uh portion of the long term plan that
has
the museum project out to 2026.
um i expected to accept the degree of
work that staff have put in this has
been a massive document
but i'm getting a wide range of
committee feedback
regarding the project being too far out
into the future
currently proposed for a five and a half
year period
where the report we got in 2020
suggested it was a three-year project
i accept this plan is probably going to
be adopted today and so
my reason for being an opposition is
uh the wish to prompt rate payers and
organizations in our community that have
said to me that they're
not happy about the museum and the
eyesight
being closed for that period of time to
come forward and make some
some presentation to the consultation
process
putting aside the scope issue which is
something that counselor pontia raised
the other day about
we may end up having some feedback that
maybe option c
is not the preferred option for the
committee and putting aside the
affordability issue
which orders uh recently just just
touched on
the issue of deliverable deliverability
easy
and the timeframes is the issue for me
and so
while staff and colleagues i guess have
spoken on all three of these issues
my viewers are getting to the core of
this issue about the museum and how long
it should take and how much lead in time
we need
it's a little bit i guess like peeling
an onion every time i remove a layer
um it just seems to have another layer
my eyes weep every every single time i
do it
um just a quick reflection back with
your blessing chair um
about the history of this museum um back
in 2011 which is ten years ago the long
term player had a commitment
from museum redevelopment um
and to quote it it said a museum
redevelopment opportunity to transform
the facility into
a first-class regional museum
unfortunately that that wasn't delivered
and we've had a second go since then
we've obviously had a series of
earthquake problem building status
reports
and that led to um the
icc removing the staff and the museum
closing
we've also had the tim walker report
which was extensive
but that was never tabled by smag with
icc
so that's left it in sort of limbo for
quite some time and the museum's been
closed for three years
and there is some degree of skepticism
in the community around
um iwaka to here as well so just
leading into this long-term plan i guess
there's two issues that drive my
opposition um one is that we did an
invocable levels of service research
document back in
august 2020. so that spoke to
key stakeholder groups in the community
and about roughly 800 people would
telephone
and it was an interesting report because
in the summary on page five
it says strengthen and develop the
museum was the top priority for
for the people in the community that
rated fifty percent next one down was
the water tower at 29
alternate water supply at 27 and the
list just went further down
so that gave a really really strong
message later in the same year 2020 we
had a community engagement process
on the priority and i was partied to
some of those um
face-to-face sessions we had and the
museum was absolutely the top priority
so um when i consider the options that
we've got i consider we have adequate
funding
there's been issues thrown up about the
work capacity of industries to deliver
a big project like this i've had
feedback from two large construction
firms
that they have capacity to do the work
the issue of our ability to recruit a
project manager is still there
and on the issue of the collection
storage i've been able to identify there
is 800 square meters
of atmospherically controlled space
potentially available for sensitive
artifacts
within the city and so i think that some
of those
layers of the onion
i guess are roadblocks i guess that we
should we should bring that project
forward
um and the last couple things i'd just
like to contribute is that there is a
degree of
skepticism within our community around
our ability to um
to deliver projects uh two good examples
was the water tower that was
approved by this council um 2018 and to
date
hasn't been delivered and the protracted
time that we took to get the chinese
garden over the line
i accept that we have a new elt group
and i accept that they're
they've got an enthusiasm but in the
last
um review that we did of the long term
plan of 2018 we had five projects in the
first four years
none of those have been finalized in
fact all but one of them hasn't even
been started
and so i guess there's a degree of
skepticism
in the community that we should have
built the long term plan
around the museum and made everything
secondary to our ability to deliver that
so based on that um i won't support
only on the assumption that i want the
community to come forward and have their
voice because they keep coming to me but
i can't deal with it
on a council by council basis it just
needs to be
it needs to come through the process
thanks counselor clark just uh
by way of clarification though even
though you've expressed an opposition
you are open to hearing
what comes in the public comments sorry
i should have should have said that um
and certainly after the consultation
process if if the outcome is
option c or b or d and it's a six year
project then that's the process
yeah i certainly will not be any
opposition to that once we've done our
consultation
the ball is now back in the community
call i agree and
and thanks for provoking the discussion
which hopefully members of the community
uh respond to it is worth noting just
before i come to you councillor craic it
is worth noting that
the two previous attempts to have the
redevelopment
project undertaken smag
itself was looking to facilitate
a a joint project between
three councils and other organizations
whereas in this instance it
uh we'll certainly talk to its partners
but the city council is in
a position where it can drive the
project so i guess that's one of the
differences that should help get it
across the board
and we're looking at more than the four
and a half million that was originally
premised
but promised in the first long-term plan
but um but thanks for making the
comments just make one one other
observation which
i think rhiannon raised at our last
meeting was that this
this roadmap is now talking about years
as calendar years as opposed to
financial years
and that's that's changed the dialogue a
little bit
true so to clarify councillors
yes for the public so as to simplify
the the roadmap is talking about
calendar years but that does not change
any of the financial modeling
underneath it's just simplified it for
the purposes of communication yep
thank you thanks councillor crackit oh
thank you mr chair
um i'm actually with councillor clark on
this one but not an opposition
just in that feedback is just of the
utmost importance on this
um as he stated our community has told
us that they're really unhappy with a
number of closures across the city and
they have been
for a while and while we're in
conjunction with our
skilled officers and industry
specialists formed the plan that we're
currently calling our roadmap to renewal
so
opening those facilities and
strengthening those facilities and
getting those facilities back up and
running
as it's been stated this ltp is really
ambitious
the size of our capital works project is
quite extensive
it's the largest that we've seen in an
extremely long time
my concern is to our community i do not
want to
over promise and under deliver these
projects
as we have had in the past a history of
doing that
while we might have our differences of
opinion
as individual counsellors as you've seen
here with councillor clark today
so well individuals in our community and
it's really important to respect those
opinions and that's why
throughout this process um this council
to have arrived at this roadmap to
renewal has been united in our approach
of what we want to take out to the
community
to get those discussions started
it's ambitious right now it's important
that we get the feedback
the feedback and having that dialogue is
what's most important
and i'm happy to confirm
the recommendations in the report and um
move those mr chair
thanks do we have a mover obviously
sorry you were there that's right thank
you my apologies counselor
uh councillor scout thank you
um i can only endorse councillors
clark's comments really in the sense
of the homework he's done the passion
that he's given on this particular
project which is dear to his heart and
dear to
all our hearts to be honest and it's
clear that
over time for whatever reason we haven't
been able to get
this one across the line and counselor
clark is correct there is a massive
community expectation i have a massive
respect also for erin and the work that
she's done around
not just this project but all the
projects but i guess here in the
question for you is
in flexibility there's three things been
outlined really that council clark's
alluded to um today um in the sense of
and i guess they're moving targets in
the
procurement of a obviously a project
manager obviously someone who can build
the thing
and obviously the the storage facility
but i think the concern for all of us if
we're honest with ourselves is just that
at miss generation where we haven't had
a museum and it seems a long
way out that 2026 all i'm asking is
is it possible within that flexibility
line given with current building is that
we could
well we i know you'll continue to look
at it but we need some encouragement i
guess
in our community certainly does because
i can tell you now
going out to community consultation it
will be
very strong in favor of the museum i
would imagine
i would imagine i'm very careful
chairman could you be very careful and
make sure the questions go through me
rather than director erin
oh certainly i'll go through you and
then you might flick to erin well i
might not need to
oh and i'd like you to if you would but
anyway um
i'll just finish thanks so i fully
endorse
council clarks i think if there's any
way we can move this
particular project forward any possible
way
that i think we should put all our
energy into it
thank you councillor let me start
answering your question with firstly i
think we should wait to hear what it is
that people have to say
rather than jumping to conclusions
secondly the answer is yes
you can change timetables but the
question that the council will have to
deal with then is what do you shift out
because for one thing to come in uh
something else is going to have to go up
because it's
only so much debt that we're able to to
raise
to be able to carry out the projects
we've been made aware of
you know potential issues around
resourcing
obviously we're all acutely aware and
and none more than me of how long this
project's taken
we were getting somewhere and then the
stadium fell over
that's not a pointed comment um
we we put the project on the back burner
because the community could only afford
so much and we recognized the value of
what needed to happen
we re-scoped it but in the meantime
the operation and
governance of smack has come under
review
uh which actually glass outfall leaves
us in a much better position to get the
project going forward so like i say yeah
timelines can change but it's a game of
tetris and we're gonna have to figure
out what else
we can shift out in order to be able to
afford that i can see you looking and
i'll go to her just to check to see that
i'm right
but did you hear what i said i did so
i'll set a test later erin is there
anything i've missed
low seat thank you mr chair
um i think i'd just reiterate the
comment that was made
um the council and the community can
decide on a program
and frankly council officers will do
their darndest to deliver it
but that being said it's already been
noted that this is a big step up for us
we haven't been in a position where we
have been delivering capital programs
with this number of projects and this
number of value
the maturity in doing that the team
to do that doesn't come from nowhere and
we are in a position where we need to
put together a team to do that at a time
where the rest of the country is already
trying to compete with us for those
those same resources
so obviously we'll go out to the
community we'll see where they feel
those priorities
sit um but to reiterate the point made
if we actually want to have something
that we think we have our best
chance of delivering on and improving
our reputation
as delivering for our community then we
want a program that we think is
realistic and if the museum comes in
then then what else pushes out
thanks aaron um it's also worth
noting first of all the comments that
andy made
in the audit opinion around risk
and observers of the news over the
weekend will notice that
uh carter holt harvey is starting to
hold back on timber which is
going to affect some activity in the
construction area uh
beck's then councillor thanks chair
um i was just going to reiterate what
the auditor said about the capital works
program that we've already got in the
ltp um it's extensive it's full
and part of that is because we've
already made some decisions to push
ahead with some projects
um and we've done that despite the fact
that the museum as councillor clark
said came back as the priority in the
community feedback that's already been
done
and i've just been thinking about the
2018 ltp
where we had those five projects where
none of them have actually happened
and i feel like if we're not careful we
might make the same mistake again
and that we front load our ltp with too
many things and then because we're
trying to do too much we don't actually
achieve anything
so i'm really interested to hear
feedback from the community
i would really encourage the community
to think about if
the museum is a priority and they would
like that moved forward
what things they would like to see us
pushing out
or changing in the ltp so that we can do
that if it is humanly possible
and i'd really encourage the community
to give us feedback
whether it's for or against or a little
bit for and a little bit or a little bit
against because sometimes i think we
only encourage the
feedback against things in the ltp but i
think it's really good to hear
feedback from people who
are happy with what's in there or happy
with parts of what is
in there and i'd also just
you know i'm a big advocate for
community engagement and i think we've
got a great community engagement plan
for this ltp as long as covert doesn't
muck it up again like it did last time
but i think we also have to remember
that the feedback we get from the
community
is only one part of the information that
we have to use when we're making
decisions
we still have to consider all of the
other parts of the information that we
receive including the professional and
staff advice
and those kinds of things and i think
that we all have to bear that in mind as
we go through the decision
decision-making
or the consultation process and the
decision-making process as a result of
that
thanks councillor amundsen uh councillor
partner
thank you chair look at 10 years
looking at long-term plans and looking
at the potential museum
redevelopment i'm i finally
have confidence that we are on the we
have the right roadmap
to get this done the way it's
been strategically put um
and i really don't know the i can't
understand the fuss
before consultation but you know
people are entitled to the views my my
view
is about is the importance of getting
this project
right because i believe looking to the
future generations
is more important than just getting a
rush job done
for current generations and i'm worried
a wee bit of
political interference that will
interfere with this long term
ideal of of creating something very
special that in 50 years
time when we're not here people go wow
they actually took the time to get that
right and they didn't just rush it
through
to tick a box so
look i'm happy with the timeline because
i'm purely about
quality and what's going to be for our
future generations and i can
see that we have the right plan for that
so that's where i sit and i again i
welcome the
consultation thank you councillor soper
thank you mr chair um it won't come as a
surprise to anyone that i'm a great
believer in the democratic process
and in the and in the invitation we make
to
air public through consultation
documents to give us the feedback
so i'm also very much committed to the
importance of keeping an
open mind at all times throughout my
political life both
centrally and locally that is an
extremely important aspect
so i'm not going to make any
any value judgments at the moment except
to say that we have
something to go out to consultation that
we are seriously
asking the public to give us feedback on
and i really do urge from a long career
in listening to
submissions that if if members of our
public
are going to give us feedback and that
feedback comes down
to we would like changes in the timing
of what's proposed
that they do give us an idea of what
they would like moved out delayed
held up for a long length of time what
they are prepared to give up
in order to change timings and also
what rate increase they would see as
acceptable we are in very tight
financial margins
a great deal of planning has gone into
what's presented
if people do want to give us the idea
that things should be moved around
can they give us some quite detailed
input not just
a simple no we don't like that
particular aspect but
we do really like the idea of moving
that forward
and we would be prepared for a slight
rate and increase to
to achieve that that that would be very
helpful to us
um and since there has now been quite a
bit of conversation on on how important
consultation is
i do just say to the to the public it is
really important to give us
your detailed opinions thank you
thank you any other questions or
comments your worship
thank you mr chair the um
there's a lot of misinformation rattling
around an issue like this and one of
them is
that this generation may not have the
benefits of a museum
but i take little decline
to the museum regularly it's the
maritime museum and love
which is our port one of the most
valuable
assets and
the tourism factor also
comes into play i was on a board in
auckland
and we were testing where tourists
actually arrived the gateway to new
zealand
and it's clearly the museum that's where
they look at a
nation's culture where they look at
how the people live and and want to
experience
what they have come across and
so i'm backing in this case
consultation as well thank you worship
look thank you councillors for the
discussion because i think glass half of
what we've done
is shine a light on an issue that we
know has been
at the forefront of people's minds
through uh pre-consultation and
certainly through the previous
um ltp but it's also given us a chance
to highlight for the media and those in
attendance what some of the issues are
around it as well
so that's been really useful i thank you
for that
it's been moved and seconded councillors
i'll now put the motion all in favor
against councillor clark would you like
your vote recorded thank you
thank you okay councillors
uh that concludes everything for the
extraordinary uh performance policy and
partnerships committee so
i'll declare it closed and we will start
the extraordinary council meeting in
just a moment
andy are you sticking around for that um
as you wish i've heard
if you've got stuff to do that's that's
fine uh essentially we're going through
the process of confirming what we've
just been
talking about so okay so i'll take my
leave in thanks
thank you very much for your time okay
thank you bye
oh and i forgot to mention the riverton
museum
where you play a formidable role it's a
brilliant little movie and there's also
hey
your worship and i'm going to be in the
black panther
movie movement yes
which i'm really looking forward
[Music]
apologies from councillor abbott
move the apology of worship uh and and
with lindsey mckenzie as well you
worship i'm happy to second that
thank you it's been moved and seconded
any discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
means carried uh
move on to the interest register no
changes there thank you
consider items in the public agenda
report of and adoption
oh yes and sorry my nose is
thank you consider the items on the
public agenda the report and adoption of
the long-term plan
consultation
document and supplementary report
material
uh rihanna you're taking us through this
again
thank you your worship so this is now
just the opportunity
to formally adopt all of those materials
just discussed and confirmed at the last
meeting the performance policy and
partnerships committee
prior to consultation commencing
tomorrow
thank you councillor thank you worship
uh look i'm happy to move the through
recommendations i know that
recommendation too we've not only gone
through the alphabet but there are a few
letters we've managed to double up on as
well
which is spectacular rihanna and i think
it's the first time we've done it
while that's a light-hearted comment um
i have
said to people over the past couple of
months you know starting from towards
the end of last year
that i feel that this is the most
engaged
council has been going through a
long-term plan
process and getting ready for what it is
that we take out
for consultation and bearing in mind
that we've had to go through all that at
the same time as we've been dealing with
the dia
uh issues is is no mean feat for for us
as councillors but also for the staff
who have an enormous amount of work that
they've um had to do to
prepare first of all what it is for
pre-consultation
then prepare what it is that we want to
take out for consultation and we're
actually
halfway through you know and and the
time frames
are tight admittedly between uh when
we've completed that consultation
process
um gone through the hearings and go
through the decision-making process
with that those two joys uh yet to come
but thank you very much rhiannon and
and everybody that you've been working
with uh michael
claire for your leadership over this
process as well
um to get us to this point
with the method of engagement that we've
had as a council
is is no mean feat and it is appreciated
thank you worship
thank you any further comments
questions
[Music]
oh
the pressure
the end of the meeting and we now have a
workshop didn't we
all right to clear the meeting closed
the night stream
you